so i'm trying the arm drag
uh knee pull but the dude is really
strong he's going to give you the
opening
to take the balloon speed hips
then over base okay
when you take this base what you're
trying to realize is that
you're inside of a spiral and the thing
with spirals why they're so awesome in
aikido
is that you can keep extending them okay
so he can do the same too so there's
going to be some residual inertia
as you come around or he can throw me
now
so as soon as you enter the yin phase
of the front part of the front ember
kazushi
you need to let go of it it's done its
job
it's not going to post so let's say he
goes to post
that's not going to do its job so that's
when i let go of it
so once i let go of it i go and secure
and let all that residual momentum pass
out to just disappear
out base out when you face out
[Music]
bring your legs here
not here here
here and weight goes on him
okay here so i'm resting on him
not on my hands i'm making him
uncomfortable
and i'm here chest weight you feel it
okay all right let's try
this is what you don't want
because i know i lost it so i'm going to
go right away for the trap
go right here and then i just have to
worry about that on
i'm looking for that foot then i just
deal with that
and i'll have that
[Music]
so i'm here done his job
and i'm in tight so he can't get that
those legs
that's how i'm gonna wait for him to
stop
okay not down here away tight
and i do this so even now
when he bridges it's hard because he's
just taking me into my hands go back
he goes you can just move your hands
because you're also not on his center
you're a little above it so
i want you to try the regular mount
escape
boom pop and try it
and this guy is just going to go ahead
and go can't get the arm
lose the arms and just keep pushing
weight into his head
that's how you settle right i'm trying
my knee full arm drag keep close
up up come around boom base out
get rid of the residual and pressure is
on his face
okay people who don't know
put their face up and you just start
crushing their nose so tap when you
don't like it
okay you see so you're gonna put
pressure on
on their face or their head
it's quite instinctual for people to
start trying to get that pressure
off of you so he's gonna push okay
and what i want to do is waste his
energy so
i make him do a bench press i don't try
to force my way down
i let him waste energy so i relax
but if i relax all the way go back
he won't get it at all
do you see so you're going to make you
want to make him work
as long as possible but of course not
so much that you um risk being thrown
so i make him i will hold only enough
tension to where he thinks he's going to
get something out of it okay when you
have a couple options
he pushes up i go there and then i relax
i can do that and he'll not be able to
hold me
or he comes up um knocks just enough and
then i'm going to swim
in and go right back to my base when i
swim in
you don't knock his arms down you do
your art
so you come in
he goes just enough come in
come in regain your base
okay so mixture of relaxation
wait make them waste energy make them
think they're accomplishing something
and then don't contest the shoulder push
come inside of it
regain your base and what do you think
he's gonna do
he's like almost got you last time i'm
gonna try it again go ahead please
you're wasting energy
okay try it again again there's not
there's not two
arms so um
[Music]
when i when i'm here and my hand lift my
hand with my head lift my head
okay go ahead and lift my head with my
hand
it's just my relaxation that gets it so
he's up
100 laps as i relax okay it's the same
thing when i throw
boom much heavier than it looks
uh he can feel the weight on it well
it's the same thing here
so i have to relax my tension actually
makes me more
liftable makes me lighter okay
so you're gonna have a fear reaction
when you feel your base coming up so
you're going to chance and he's going to
be able to lift you
so instead you relax just release the
tension
and he's working now when it comes here
your tension is what's making him stuck
on stuck on you
so again if if you relax do you see
you can become slippery so
when you get up here don't go tense
because
you feel the ledge i'm giving you i'll
relax the ledge do you see
relax the ledge okay
so the movement should look like this is
up
relax much come back down way back on
his face
okay now what that does
helps me because i don't want although
i'm guarding his waistband
and his pocket somewhat he can still
reach
and i don't know if he's armed or not so
if i throw the guy i'll go to secure my
base
hopefully he pushes up on my chest and
now i know where his arms are
okay if he does not push up on my chest
i'm very concerned about where his
where his arms are so he'll bring his
arms up so
boom boom and he'll bring his arms up
okay so i'll find my face the guy's not
pushing on me
just pop right in the face just make him
bring his arms up to protect his face
if there's an arm that's staying back
there right
um you're gonna have this space
underneath you so come up
and bring that arm up
and we're going to go for more of a high
a high mount on this
okay so my arms are up here his arms are
up here
so strategy again and the residual
inertia
his hands stay back there he didn't push
on me give him a reason pop
find the other arm bring the other arm
up away from his waistband
okay and now i'm so high on him i'm
gonna be better up coming up on the
up on this high mount here okay and get
his arms
in this position if you can't get all
the way
just scoop his arms up and then you'll
be in this high mount here
okay all right let's try it
okay when i go to punch
i don't punch like this i want to leave
with the knuckles
so this one boom
and my weight stays down so there's
still weight on your face right
okay this is where i'm punching now now
the arm came up
so i worry about the other arm
in here
so we land boom he didn't do the
instinctual thing of getting weight
so i'm concerned bob get his hand up and
i seek to get the other hand up high
and then i'm in this position okay
try it again punch the right way and
leave weight on the head when you punch
go and it's there you have to you have
to learn uh
strategy and tactics okay
so you can't just have an obscure move
so that's
we're giving you some context here of
course drill the tactic
but try to understand the context so
that's why
uke has a prescribed role because uk is
setting up the context
which is where you learn the strategy
okay so
i understand when i when i extend the
spiral
you can extend it back so learn how to
to disseminate the residual inertia of
the first throw okay
put weight on them see if you get that
instinct
to get that weight off of them and then
use that to tire them
be cognizant of the dude that's not
instinctually pushing up
that person is either unconscious hit
their head on the throw
or that person is grabbing a weapon
right and so let's go with the guy
that's grabbing a weapon let's get their
hands where i can see them
move them away from their waistband or
even my weapons that are on my person
get their hands up
because of how we got there you're going
to be able to step
underneath their armpits and get this
high mount okay
now the next person though is gonna be
the more trained
person so uh if you did your your part
right they're not gonna be able to get
your foot trapped they're not gonna be
able to
use the residual inertia but they will
get a position uh that makes it much
harder for what you're doing okay
in particular they will put their hands
up high but they will
have their elbows inside your legs so
that last guy
brought their hands up high but because
they did it too late
his elbows were outside my legs that's
what allowed me to get the high mount
okay
so as we go to throw and i realized i
lost this thing
i put my elbows inside so try the high
mount
he's not gonna ever get it okay so sit
up so they can see
my elbows are tight against my body i
have my guard here so he comes back down
he's gonna be trying his weight i'm just
hanging out
i don't get triggered by weight he goes
to punch
my hands are up where they need to be or
even just my body he goes to punchers
and just moving my body okay
but my hands are here now okay
all right let's have luke get there i
secured my face
he's more trained and we picked the
mountain reversal so he goes to get the
trap
okay and again make him think he's gonna
get it so
again if i'm here and i have my
extension go
he's never he's never gonna get so i
just
go make him work almost gotta do and
then
on this one leave your elbow there roll
around it
again don't contest and come back out
oh almost got it then leave your elbow
there
roll around it come back out let's have
him go around the outside
same thing just you'll never get it but
make him work
almost got it and then you're going to
drop the same shoulder in
and you'll buck out okay let's go back
to the one where he's on the inside so
let's look at what he's doing he goes
i'm making him work making it work
making him work when i go you're gonna
try to go around there you go
okay so i'm going here he feels me going
around
you're going to tempt him with that
so pop down
and now you created this free corner
here okay
and that's what i want so i know where
that arm is
i know where that arm is and i have my
bone puncher
pop pop elbow
okay so i'm doing my strategy
he's going in i want you to go slow so
you see it i'm going to come around
and when i get on the inside here that's
when i step with my knee inside
and now i created this zone of attack
so i can punch from here boom boom
or my elbows okay all right let's try
that
okay so he's trying the mount reversal
right
so he he didn't go for the bottom
um trap first he's going for the the
top part okay so he's going go ahead so
he's
well he's getting it and then we go
[Music]
let me reverse it
so we had the one where he's going
inside the arm
come on dude back
so when he's going inside the arm i'm
fine the same strategy get him to work i
swim inside and i
pin and i create this attack zone here
okay
just keep your weight down and hit
now we're doing the one where the guy
comes outside so i'm gonna i have this
reversal here
okay so what i'm gonna do is he goes
this is where i step in right there and
then
out and then i have the same attachment
on this side
so you again making him think
almost there almost there but you're
thinking he's bringing this to my knee
where i'm gonna go
and then i reverse
pop pop okay
let's go